hey what's going on you
far right conspiracy theorists how you
doing people i'm dave rubin this is a
bonus
mini reuben report direct message for
today march 19th
2021 as you know we already put up our
friday bonanza
panel this morning with richie mcginnis
from the daily caller
and with lauren chen and with sarah
gonzalez from the blaze i normally
only do uh one show a day but
joe biden fell and everyone's freaking
out and i had to be in studio anyway
because in about an hour from now i'm
doing an event that'll be actually live
streamed on the on the facebook there uh
with students for liberty
uk we're doing that uh in about an hour
from now so i was already
in studio had the jacket on and we
thought all right let's talk about this
biden thing
and it's not about bite and falling
we're going to show you the video of
biden falling
i'm guessing that most of you who are
online creatures right you're people of
the internet
you've probably seen the video already
of biden falling today on
his way up the stairs getting on air
force one
and look people fall let's get all the
disclaimers out first
people fall people fall down the stairs
and sometimes people fall up the stairs
the falling up of the stairs is always
sort of funnier and more ridiculous
because you generally think gravity is
going to take you down but every now and
again
you might miss a step you might have a
a uh you know a slippery shoe
there could be something on the floor it
could be a little windy the white house
is now saying it was very windy there's
no evidence that it was very windy
it was a mild breeze and as you'll see
when you see the video in a moment it
had
clearly nothing to do with the wind but
anyway the point is this is not about
the guy
falling people fall what i want to focus
on just for the 10 or so minutes that
we're going to do this live stream is
the media reaction
or i should say the media lack of
reaction because you guys may remember
when donald trump lifted a glass
with two hands remember he drank water
this is coffee but he drank water with
two hands and people wrote many many
pieces
about how he might have parkinson's or
there's something wrong with him or he's
having neurological problems or all
sorts
of mainstream pieces right then of
course we remember donald trump walking
down that ramp
that he gingerly walked down and
apparently it had rained a little bit
before and he walked gingerly down and
everybody everywhere was telling us that
there's something wrong with him and he
doesn't have balance and all the rest of
it well okay
flash forward the last year and we've
seen endless episodes of joe biden not
knowing where he is not knowing what
he's saying
reading teleprompters wrong forgetting
that he's the president and not kamala
harris a series of things
okay it is what it is it's not really
being covered by mainstream media as i
keep saying the scandal is
the non-scandal the scandal is not that
there's something wrong with joe biden
everyone
that has half a brain understands that
already the scandal is the non-scandal
meaning the fact that the mainstream
media is hiding something that we can
see in front of our faces
which is what they do right buildings
blowing up behind ali velshi on msnbc
and he's telling you it's a largely
peaceful protest mainstream media is
punking you
all the time so let's go to the video
this is biden boarding
air force one today
okay i will be totally honest with you
look i've given biden a hard time
obviously i didn't vote for biden i
think the democratic party is is
in many ways destroying anything
remotely close to an america that i want
to live in
um but you know the president of the
united states is the guy that's
flying the plane right that's an analogy
i've heard some people use he's flying
the plane and
whether you like the pilot or not or you
like
everything about him or not you want the
pilot to be able to fly the plane
there's obviously something wrong with
this guy now he just fell there
when i initially saw it this morning and
i knew it was going to explode right you
can just see when you see a viral video
with just a couple
views and you're like oh this thing is
just going to catch fire and grow go
across the internet
my initial feeling was not like it's
funny or it's great or anything like
that like
immediately i started bouncing around my
mind like what are the funny parts of
this like the
you know i feel i've fallen and i can't
get up video from way back when and or
peter uh from family guy falling ah
ah like you've all seen all these things
right so there's like a lot of funny
things but like the fact that this old
man is basically being abused and that
there's so many people
that know it and even putting all of
that aside even if he was 100
watching a 78 year old man the president
of the united states fall
uh and struggled to get up a couple
times i mean in essence he fell three
times there
like it's it's not the most fun thing in
the world and again that's not why i'm
doing
this video i'm doing this video for a
reason that we're going to get to in
just a moment let's just watch it again
because he
falls three times
okay so obviously we know what the media
is going to do they're either going to
ignore it or cover up for it as i said
the white house said it had something to
do with the wind it had nothing to do
with the wind
so what i did because i'm a crack
detective over here people and we don't
have journalists anymore so me
sitting here in my sweatshorts i'm
wearing uh air jordan jumpman 23
sweatpants right now by the way
sweatshirts
i decided let me do a little googling
because maybe i can do a little
something
somewhat close to in the ballpark of
journalism and
i took a video i googled it on my phone
you know something about
uh trump uh falling down the stairs or
trump
uh what was the exact phrase that i used
let's pull it up there yeah we can pull
it up i want to get the exact i want to
quote myself correctly
it was trump going down the ramp
something to that effect that's what i
put in google and then i just did a
video so you're looking at the video
right now and we're just scrolling
through
and there's page after page of articles
uh you know worrying about trump's
health because he walked down the ramp
slowly
and it's new york times and it's wapo
washington post it's cnn
it's yahoo it's new york magazine it's
people magazine it's vanity
fair it's forbes it's the whole bunch of
them
let's just show that again because uh i
think it's worth noting like there's
just
like an endless amount of articles this
literally took me one second to do
and it's like do you think now that all
of these places that i just mentioned
the new york times washington post
vanity fair cnn do you think they're
going to be writing articles about
biden's health and how this is evidence
of something as they did
with trump of course not and that's why
this is the bigger issue
that's why i spend so much time talking
about the media because
it doesn't matter in a way in a very
depressing way what is true
if we can't get to what is true because
the media causes a filter
for you to see certain things one way
and then when it goes against their
narrative
to see it another way so a guy by the
name of drew holden who's a good
follower
on twitter at drew holden 360. not that
anyone should be on twitter
right before i started so we didn't have
time to put the images up
he tweeted out two images from the new
york times so the new york times today
in response they finally did comment on
the joe biden falling thing which by the
way twitter trends
last i checked a few minutes ago didn't
even show biden falling even though
that's all that everyone's talking about
it has like a whole bunch of other
nonsense on there but the new york times
did
write a piece about biden falling it
says president biden
was doing a hundred percent fine after
falling off balance while boarding air
force one
on friday according to a press secretary
the president
exited the plane when he arrived in
atlanta without
an issue okay well that's what the press
secretary said that sounds right but
then of course
drew holden and this is why some people
hate twitter because we can catch
you we can catch what you guys used to
do new york times here's the new york
times headline on donald trump
with the ramp trump's halting walk down
ramp raises new health questions the
president also appeared to have trouble
raising a glass of water
to his mouth during a speech at west
point a day before he turned 74
the oldest a president has been in his
first term
do you see do you see what i'm talking
about there so one
is press secretary said he felt fell
came off the plane he was just fine the
other one
new questions we've got questions people
and he drank water slowly uh
you see so look that that's what the
problem is that's what the problem is
that we are we are stuck
fighting it's not that we have good and
bad or right and wrong or left and right
or conservative or liberal or all of
those things
that would seemingly be a fair fight on
the same plane
we have basically democrats
and the media versus the rest of us i
don't even have to say conservatives
there or
just disaffected liberals or whatever it
is it's just like this
machine that lies to protect the
democrats that
is consumed that has in essence taken
over the new york times
and washington post and all of the
places where people get mainstream media
and it's just
it's just a problem it's just a problem
uh that being said i don't like leaving
you guys on friday with
problems so if you are interested do
tune in in about 45 minutes from now to
my event
uh with students for liberty we're
actually i think we're doing a full book
review we have unlimited i said i don't
want any questions in advance
a book review of don't burn this book
it's from uh the good folks at students
for liberty uk
so if you just search their facebook
page we'll be live streaming
right here and that'll roll us into the
weekend and more than anything else i
hope
i hope you have a nice weekend relax
don't be too political
if you want to hang out with me and chat
and talk and and see what we're eating
and drinking
and what music we're listening to and
some dog pictures and i talk to tons of
people
on the app all the time join us at
reubenreport.locals.com of course you
can download the locals app either in
the apple app store or on google play if
you've got the android
and just one more reminder our friday
panel
was this morning with richie mcginnis
from daily caller sarah gonzalez from
blaze tv and
lauren chen who's one of my favorite
political analysts of the day
we talk all about media bias actually so
it quite fits what i just did here all
right have a great weekend everybody
and i'll see you on monday
you